- Joel, there was some tricks.
You guys were shooting
in some very cold weather
and Will was very helpful with that.
Was he not?
- I mean there was, they have rain towers
that they like took from
the ground water in Toronto.
It was like icy cold.
We were all just like miserable in that.
And then Will had the
brilliant idea of getting in,
like the bucket of steaming hot water.
- [Will] Yeah.
- And he'd get this little bucket
and he'd like sneak up to people
that were like standing
and shivering to death
and then he'd like pour
it down their necks.
And you could just like
see people standing there
and then they were like
(moans in appreciation)
(laughing)
It was like...
- [Will] Yeah.
- [Joel] It was sensual.
- It was so not!
(laughing loudly)
And you could see like,
and he was going around
and he was running around
like a little kid in the candy store.
He was like (giggling)
(laughing loudly)
And he was like pouring it.
And then it like caught on,
so everybody was taking
these little buckets
and like pouring on each other.
It was time like a little weird.
(laughing loudly)
Everybody was like,
- [Voiceover] A little weird.
- Everybody was like (moans loudly)
(laughing)
And the whole crew was
like looking at us like--
- Get me, Joel.
Get me, get me.
(laughing loudly)
I got you.
I got you, bro.
(moans loudly)
- Man.
(laughing loudly)
- Oh, Joel. Thank you.
- You want a little spa though.
- [Will] Yeah!
- [Voiceover] A little spa!
I like that.
- And then the sound guys,
they were not so happy.
Cause we were pouring water...
- [Both] Into their microphones.
- Yeah.
- So we would ruin--
- They were would yell
or like killing us here.
- It was very warm
but you guys won't hear
any of the dialogue.
- No, no, no, a lot of crackling
and shorting out through most of the film.